red notice you look awesome what are you
wearing are we allowed to ask steam uh
armani giorgio armani
yeah nice yeah he makes stuff
like clothes and things
tell me about this move dude this thing
was like indiana jones meets double 07
with a whole lot of funny wha what
the big three i've coined you guys the
big three what are fans gonna love most
about this i think just seeing the
dynamic between the three of us you know
we're we've all known each other for
years and years and years i've known
dwayne for uh over 20 years
i'm sort of dating both of us at that
point but he goes down with me so
um yeah a long time so there's a real
kind of natural chemistry there that you
can't really make up and you know it's
just like a big old-fashioned
swashbuckling
comedic adventure and and it's the kind
of movie i grew up on and loved and uh
i'm really really excited about it it
delivers everything it promises indeed
it does i watched it like two hours ago
and i i can't even get to the ending
it's insane what happens um
has anybody asked you this uh is it
wonder woman black adam or deadpool who
wins in a fight who wins in a fight well
i mean black adam we don't really know
we can't rush to judgment for all the
facts are in there um i guess you know
that's going to be a it's going to be a
weird fight i'm kind of unkillable
i don't know what wonder woman status is
there in the unkillable department
although she seems fairly unkillable
and then dwayne i don't know dwayne's
going to just go right away with black
adam i think gal is going to have a
little humility about it and say wonder
woman or or probably black adam
and i'm just going to go with wonder
woman
i'm just going to go with wonder woman
we'll take it wonder woman for the win
netflix has said this is one of their
more expensive films do you feel any
more pressure to succeed and deliver
because of that
no i don't know if it's like the most
expensive movie or any of that sort of
stuff i'm not really privy to that i did
not produce this one dwayne would know
that he would know actual numbers and i
urge you to quiz him on that um but uh
it is a big movie i mean it's a big
movie but you know netflix came to play
and i think they've uh they've sort of
made no bones about that
yeah i mean the movie is absolutely
gigantic um you've recently said you're
going to take some time away from movies
now
if it's not too much can i ask you
finish spirited did will ferrell drive
you away from movies
just the opposite will gave me will is
like one of those people that is
everything you would hope dream and pray
he would be off screen as well he's just
such a wonderful human being so if
anything he gave me some major pause but
but he's a lot like me he's a his family
means everything to him and
you know for me it's it's really about
getting some quality time with my kids
before they're uh before they're you
know teenagers who loathe me
read the room
i just want the eggs
[Music]